Especially when like older male virgins get ridiculed, like, why don't you like,
you know, having a girlfriend or say, why aren't you getting married soon or,
Oh, you're an insolvent, right?
Oral sex counts as losing your virginity. Three,
two, one go.
I mean, I believe that we call it oral sex for a reason,
because you get the same benefits from somebody's mouth as you would from
vaginal intercourse. So it is sex.
I think I agree with that. Cause it's like growing up that's that's what sex is.
It's right. It's the full, like the whole thing. But that makes sense.
Cause you're getting to the same end goal. So I'm gonna go here. Well,
hearing you all say that it makes me rethink kind of I've just always assumed
it's just penetration. Yeah.
That's what I thought too. I mean, for me,
like losing my Virginia means like receiving it through my backend.
You don't know what I'm saying?
That's just like my own personal definition of like what Virginia Beach is.
I am afraid of having sex. Three, two,
one, go scary.
You said I'm afraid, right? Okay. All right. I'm definitely not afraid.
I'm Mexicano. Wait, wait. You guys are afraid of sex. Uh,
I know my path. I will get married.
I will have sex with my wife and it's going to be great.
I have no fear about that whatsoever.
I feel like exposing yourself at your Ross' former to another human being,
who I love, who you love. Yeah. Okay. That's that's true.
But you're not like at all, like even nervous. No.
Not at all. I mean, I mean, I'm talking right now,
so I don't know how be in the room,
but like if it's a person who I love and we've dated and we know each other and
we know how we work, communication is key. Um, no, I would be very comfortable.
Just in general. I just feel like I'm going to be extremely awkward.
So yeah, I'm a little scared,
but I'm not really scared of losing it to the wrong person because
no matter what I intend for it to be just this monogamous one-time thing.
But I am scared of that person.
Perhaps not being the one that I'm supposed to be with forever for the rest of
my life.
I think like a lot of the pressure does come from like porn because it paints a
picture in your mind that play like 90% of the time can't be fulfilled or
satisfied. So if I'm going to be having sex, right.
She expects like iPhone fro 12 max. And all I have is a 12 mini, you know,
like that's, that's what some guys think. Right. And like,
and you feel like you can't live up to those standards because for the most
part, you probably can't it's fake.
I heard you whisper. I don't care. And I felt the same way. Like I just,
I think that the right person wouldn't care,
maybe we just have too much time to think about these things and we put too much
pressure on ourselves for whatever reason to look a certain way or act a certain
way. And you're going to figure that out when the time is right. So why worry,
why spend your time worrying about that right now?
So maybe I'm a little bit less scared.
I'm saving myself for marriage. Three, two,
one go.
Saving myself for marriage was something I was taught growing up.
It was something very indoctrinated to my mind. So, you know,
at a young age I made that decision.
I don't want to give that part of me to somebody else.
That's not going to take that journey with them.
I think the energy exchange between me and my future wife will just be so
powerful that when we do get married, I'm just waiting for that moment.
And I know that in the future years after that moment,
it will just be great sex up to grade sex after grade sex,
just because I've waited for that moment. And it's something special to me.
So, um,
I haven't been in a relationship and I'm not sure how I would act in a
relationship.
So that's why I'm on the just agree line because I would love to save myself
from marriage. That's what I am aiming for at this point.
But I also haven't dated anybody or been in any relationship.
So I don't know how I'm going to act.
I don't know if that's going to be my first love or what type of pressure is
going to be on me.
So that's why I'm not on strongly agree because I'm still a human and I don't
know.
Have many men like asks you out on dates or like tried to date you?
Yes, but I usually run away because I'm scared.
Like what causes you to run away? Like what's like.
I think my mentality when I was young of just being afraid of
men in general, just because I'm getting pregnant where I'm from,
wasn't abnormal at a young age. So I just never wanted that to happen to me.
Just like her.
I have like zero relationship experience except no one asked me to go
out with them.
Another compelling thing for me on saving my Virginia a marriage is that,
you know, I had an unfortunate occasion on being sexually
mishandled by a girl. Uh, when I was young,
I didn't know back then it was considered, you know,
not good until later on. And it made me very protective, very selective.
I used to have that mentality of wanting to meet, wait till marriage.
That was something when I was younger, I just, for some reason,
that's what I wanted to do.
I didn't grow up in a religious home where that was something that was expected
at all. It was just a decision I wanted to make, but I think for me,
it started to evolve into when I feel comfortable,
when I feel at someone that I want to have that experience with, but I don't,
I didn't want it to be this like checkbox that I needed to have filled before I
decided to make that decision.
I enjoy watching porn three, two,
one go.
Okay. So porn does release a lot of dopamine, so we technically all do enjoy it.
But it's the, after the fact you realized like how, how horrible that was.
You're watching two people have sex through a phone screen and the bathroom.
It's kind of disgusting. I'm on like over a thousand days, no fat.
I haven't watched porn in over a thousand days.
So I was exposed to it at like 10 years old. It's not natural.
It's not healthy at all.
Um, I try not to watch it, but when I do watch it, I do enjoy it.
So I have to be honest here. Um, but I really have been trying to do more,
no fat, you know, but I'm just not to a thousand days or anything like that.
I mean, I believe watching porn, it's like a private experience. I mean, y'all,
don't like go out and say, Hey, go, Hey, y'all I watch porn and stuff. I mean,
I see watching porn is like an outlet of like my sexual frustration.
Like it helps me maintain my virginity.
Cause I haven't had sex myself and experienced that.
It's been almost a tool for me to kind of learn and understand how sex
works. Cause I didn't ever have a sex ed class or health or anything like that.
There are different types of porn, right?
Some are like more romantic and natural.
I feel like in some are a little bit crazy.
There's beauty to some that is natural and how it actually would be.
I don't think it's all bad.
You believe that what you see in the porno videos is actually how people
have sex in real life.
No, not in, not in most.
I think about having sex a lot, three, two,
one go.
For a while.
I kind of low key thought something was wrong with me because I never thought
about it at all. It's not something that ever popped up.
I always knew I was a little different because I just never thought about it or
wanted to think about it. I feel the same way actually.
I thought something was wrong too. And then one of my friends was like, well,
maybe you're asexual. And I thought I took it and I was like, is this me? Yeah.
And I kind of took offense to it.
It made me feel like something's wrong with me. You know.
I do think about it a lot. Um,
but I thought about it a lot more when I wasn't abstaining from like porn and
masturbation. I instead of just thinking about it and just either, you know,
going to place it out by just masturbating obviously,
or going to find a partner to do it with instead I just sit down crisscross.
I literally just meditate.
And then I focus on channeling that sexual desire that we're all born with.
And I channeled it into something that actually would benefit me,
like making YouTube videos, working out for me.
I constantly think more about finding the right partner for me buying the right
guy in my relationship.
I went through like really bad fallouts with like other people.
I just don't want to feel like I'm just nothing.
I just want to feel like I'm someone to someone's life outside of my family.
Our culture focuses on women's virginity more than men's
three, two, one go.
I have no idea. No, no. I just, I just, I don't know.
I feel like men are more praised when they're Virgin.
I feel like people put more attention on them whenever they are a Virgin.
It's a bigger deal. I know growing up, uh, we,
the people who I was taught by put a lot of pressure to keep yourself pure or
to, you know,
cover yourself as a woman for the sake of men either were seen as
more promiscuous if we do it or we're seen as more prude. If we don't.
I would S I would counter that by saying for a guy you're seen as like,
what's wrong with you? Like, if you're still a Virgin,
whereas if you aren't a Virgin, it's like, okay, finally, you're, you're,
you're, you're on our team now. You're normal now. So we,
we almost kind of get like, shame. Like, who's that guy, you know,
we'll take a stuff for you, bro. Oh, I think it's that.
That's true.
So women get shamed for sleeping around men get shamed for not exactly
that's messed up.
Well, especially when like older male virgins get ridiculed, like what,
why don't you let you know, having a girlfriend or, Hey,
why aren't you getting married soon or, Oh, you're or you're an insolvent,
right? It's just a different dynamic. When it comes to, you know,
being ridiculed as a female Virgin compared to like a male version.
Being a burgeon is tied to my religion. Three,
two, one go.
It is my decision,
but it is very much tied to my Catholicism and what we're taught about the
sacred,
just the holiness of the body and the soul and the value that your
virginity is not even just, you know, from a strictly biological sense,
but the fact that you're willing to wait and you're willing to put off something
that the world is trying to push on you.
Isn't it being a Virgin tied to every religion. Technically they all say like,
no premarital sex.
Well, if you're not religious though, then maybe individually,
it's not tied to your beliefs. Yes. I'm not, I'm not religious.
I don't go to church as much as I should, but it's my decision.
It's not a religion for me.
The way I see it is is God put us here for a reasons.
And most people don't follow those reasons,
but the few who do they are rewarded, um, for, for following the path.
So I almost kind of see it as almost kind of like a superpower, uh, that,
that God is like, Hey man, you're on my side. You're doing my work.
You're walking my path. Good work, like, like is going to be what, I mean,
like sex does create new life, right? So if, if you're abstaining from that,
you're not just going to get it to just about anybody.
That is a superpower because it's, it's staying within.
Your own self.
And if you can learn how to control it and channel that sexual energy through
different, by other means, you can put more work into your school,
into your job, passion hobby, instead of just having it stay as sex, uh,
sexual energy.
Right. And we'll, and, and, you know, just relying on that, um,
answer as it's my religion, you know,
staying faithful to what you believe in anything,
not just sex is it can be very difficult because we are human, you know,
human nature, just because we have the excuse or reasoning of religion,
doesn't make it any easier.
For us.
We still say goodbye, but I'm walking.